you know at the start of the show we
brought to you breaking news and now we
know more a shooting near a popular
restaurant in North Las Vegas there's a
heavy police presence near Fifth and
Craig with emergency crews treating
victims 8 news now reporter Ryan Matthey
joins us live there with what we know so
Ryan what can you tell us
Ozzy well just in the past half hour we
arrived on scene here police have
confirmed to us a six-year-old girl was
confirmed shot in this investigation and
what they also add is this potentially
began blocks away but it ended here
outside of the Olive Garden near Craig
and Fifth Street here in North Las Vegas
they add that they got calls of the
potential shooting just before 11 this
morning the car you're looking at right
now this is obviously surrounded by
several police vehicles a quick walk
around you can see a car seat in the
back and some items from the cart left
out on the sidewalk now we do know the
police again a six-year-old girl
confirmed shot and another male in his
30s confirmed shot as well both are in
stable condition at UMC trauma currently
police said this is a potential road
rage incident that began near Lone
Mountain and 5th Street just minutes
away from here but as we are still fresh
on the scene there's a lot of
information that remains unclear what we
know so far at least the Olive Garden
the McDonald's is closed down but much
else in the area seems to be open
investigators are arriving on scene
right now and will be staying here
trying to figure out exactly the
circumstances of this month this
investment for now reporting live near
Craig and fifth Brian mathie eight news
now